>>> Ladies and gentlemen, would you now please
welcome Chrix Finne and Kenneth Lui.
>>Chris Finne: My name is Chris Finne. I am
a product manager on the AdMob team at Google,
and I am here with my colleague, Kenneth.
>>Kenneth Lui: Hi, everybody. My name is Kenneth
Lui. I lead content recruitment for Android
and the Google Play Store. My job is to make
sure that there are great apps and games in
the store for users and also to make sure
that -- you know, help you guys be successful
by using the store.
>>Chrix Finne: And my job is to make the ads
on AdMob better.
We're here today to talk to you about monetizing
your Android apps. We're going to cover a
bunch of different monetization options for
you and try and actually present a framework
for how to think about monetizing your apps.
Let's get right into it.
I think that there really are three things
that any app developer or, really, any software
business, needs to think about when you're
trying to grow a business from the thing that
you've built. This has actually gone around
on the Internet a few times recently. And
it's a pretty good framework.
Number one is user engagement. It's really
the key things. This seems obvious, but it's
-- it's it; right? Like, if you don't build
an app that is useful and valuable to people
and that they keep coming back to, you've
got nothing.
So that's really the key thing for building
a business later on.
Number two is distribution. Right? Obviously,
you need to make sure that the right people
around the world know about your app, find
your app, and get -- can get their hands on
your app.
And then only at the end of the day, the third
pillar is to think about monetization. How
you're going to make money from this app that
you've built.
So if you're working on a mobile app or any
software startup, this is even maybe how I
would organize my team; right? Any activity
that you do should fall into one of these
three categories.
And, really, when you are trying to think
about monetization, which is what we're talking
about today, it doesn't work unless you have
strength in the other two categories as well.
So at Google I/O, we actually have three sessions
that cover these different categories. We're
talking right now about monetization. Following
immediately in this room, at 4:00, our colleagues
Patrick and Kushagra are going to be talking
about promoting your app, how to find new
users and distribute your app.
And then on Friday, our colleagues Neil and
Nick at 11:30 are going to talk about how
you can measure and understand your user engagement
using Google Analytics, which is a fantastic
tool for doing that.
We also have a code lab tomorrow to get in-depth
with a lot of these things and learn with
our developer team and our engineers about
how to do a lot of these things we're going
to be talking about today. That's tomorrow
at 11:45.
So, cool.
Let's talk a little bit about monetization.
We're still at the beginning of this evolution
of the mobile ecosystem. And I think most
of you probably know this. We saw a very similar
thing happen with the Web ten years ago.
Today, there's just an incredible number of
devices out there. I think the stat came out
in March that there are actually more people,
at least in the U.S., buying smartphones and
tablets than buying laptop and desktop computers
today, which is just crazy. It's hard to understate
the impact that this is going to have on computing
and on society.
So what about apps?
A few years ago, if you had a great idea for
an app, it was pretty simple. You'd put your
app up, and maybe you would charge 99 cents
for it or you throw some ads on it and hope
for the best. But things have gotten a lot
more complicated. There are many ways to monetize
your app out there. You can sell it, you can
sell stuff within the app, you can do virtual
goods, you can do subscriptions, you can do
advertising.
So one of the things that we get asked a lot
is, what monetization method should I use?
So we've thought about this. And we want to
try and show you guys a nice little framework
for thinking about this.
So here's the framework. It's not all that
simple.
This flowchart is not meant to be a -- you
know, a playbook, but it's just an illustration
of how complex the world is out there.
And, really, the point we're trying to make
is that there's no one path to monetizing
your app. Different people use apps in very
different ways. Anybody that's looked closely
at a piece of software knows that people use
it for all sorts of different things. Like,
users are diverse. And so it's really up to
you guys to understand your users and understand,
therefore, what are the best ways to monetize
depending on what your users are doing.
And if there's one thing we really want you
to take away from this session, it is just
that, that there's no one single path to maximizing
the value you get from your app. But it's
really about understanding your users and
understanding the best ways to do that, given
what they're doing.
So let's take an example.
So let's say you have a group of users that
are, you know, excited about your app and,
you know, maybe they are, I don't know, pick
a demographic, 35 to 45-year-old females in
the Midwest. They want to actually pay for
the stuff in your app. Maybe you are producing
a game that has virtual goods that they want
to kind of pay for in an ongoing way. Great.
That means you can actually do that. You should
just do that. That's a pretty direct way of
monetizing your app.
But in other examples, looking somewhere else
on the flowchart, you may have another group
of users who are not actually willing to pay
anything. Maybe they're just sort of browsing
through your app. Maybe it's an RSS reader
or something. In that case, you should think
about a different business model, in this
case, advertising.
So at Google, we have sort of two major venues
in which you can monetize your app. One is
the Google Play Store, which Kenneth is going
to cover in-depth in a minute. And the other
is, of course, indirect monetization through
advertising.
So let's turn it over to Kenneth. And he's
going to talk about all the different ways
you can monetize using Google Play.
>>Kenneth Lui: Thank you, Chrix.
So in this section of the presentation, we're
going to mainly talk about three things. The
first one is about expanding the opportunities
for monetizing applications in the Google
Play Store.
The second one is to really describe the different
options that you have and give you a high-level
overview of how to use them. And then, finally,
we're going to dive into a couple of case
studies of successful developers. Some of
the developers have been really successful
in climbing some of our top charts, top paid,
top free. But, more importantly, since this
is a monetization talk, the top grossing categories.
So we'll take a look at those and see what
are they doing right that we can learn from.
So you've all heard from Hugo this morning,
and then just now Chris, about the tremendous
momentum of the Android ecosystem.
So building any type of a business really
requires you to have a customer base. And
so the customer base for Android is really
growing very rapidly.
You might have seen me juts looking at this
clock in front of me. You don't see it. But
I'm seeing this second counting down for the
time remaining for the session. And that number
from Hugo, 12 devices a second, keeps ticking
every time I see that clock runs.
So in about the ten minutes that we started
this talk, there's about 7,000 new customers
that could potentially be consuming your services.
So the ecosystem is working really, really
well. Isn't that just amazing?
But having users alone is really not enough.
What we need to make sure is that they really
have the necessary instruments to pay for
your services. And, in other words, that means
providing different options of forms of payment
or what we call FOPs, set up that they can
actually very easily pay for your services
within the Google Play Store.
And also these different forms of payments
need to suit different user needs as well.
So in the Google Play Store, we've always
given users the option to charge by credit
card or by debit card. But, of course, not
everybody has a credit card. Many different
-- many different demographics, different
locations of users, you know, they don't actually
have access to a credit card.
So we have added direct carrier billing. And
since last year at Google I/O, we've added
five new countries and ten new carriers to
direct carrier building.
And as you've heard from Chris's talk just
earlier, direct carrier billing really has
a very, very major impact on revenues and
sales. And I'm really glad to report that
nearly 40% of Google Play users are actually
able to charge their purchases directly to
their mobile bill. So this is huge.
What's new is Google Play Balance.
So Google Play Balance introduces a new form
of payment via stored value. You're going
to be getting your new devices soon. So with
these new devices in hand, all of you will
get a $25 credit automatically added to your
Google Wallet account to spend on Google Play
content.
So as we were talking about earlier, not every
user has access to a credit card. Not every
user or device has access to direct carrier
billing, for example, if you have a Wi-Fi-only
device, you wouldn't have direct carrier billing.
So as you can imagine, there are many new
opportunities that can be opened up with stored
value.
This is still very much in the early stage,
and we're actively working this area. So please
stay tuned for more news coming up in the
near future.
Now, in addition to more users and setting
out more forms of payment, we really need
to make sure that it's easier for users to
consume your services and also provide you
as a business more flexibility to charge for
your services.
So not so long ago, deciding on a business
model in the app space was actually relatively
straightforward. You would build in an application,
and then when you're done, you kind of decide,
hey, do I want to launch it as a free application?
And maybe I have some advertising in it? Or
should I have it as a paid application? And
that's the choices you have when you go to
the publisher, you know, console, is to pick
free or paid.
It's a very simple model, but at the same
time, it also has limitations, because it
didn't have some of the capabilities needed
for today's business environment.
We now have many more options in Google Play
to cater to those needs. But that also means,
very importantly, with those options, those
added options, you really need to start thinking
about your monetization strategy not after
development, but when you design the application
and as you're developing your application.
You really kind of have to think of it as
a business of what the application is going
to do, what the game is going to do, and build
in the monetization method within it.
So without further ado, let's take a look
at what those options are, and we'll dive
into a few examples.
So let's start with free.
Free provides, as we all know, people -- users
like free. It gives you the lowest barrier
to entry to at least -- for users to at least
try out your application.
In terms of monetization, free typically means
ad-driven. Your app downloaded as free, but
you could be earning indirect revenue through
advertising throughout the lifetime of the
application.
There could be many reasons why you decide
to go this way, to be ad-driven. It could
be because paid apps are not supported. Or
it could be in certain countries or if your
content is simply more suitable for free,
that's what you will decide to do.
Chrix is going to go into this area in-depth
in the latter part of this presentation.
In premium, this is where the user pays per
title. So in Google Play, this is a one-time
charge. What that means, it's a one-time charge
that associates your user account with the
title that you purchased. That means that
if you paid for an application, even though
you may change your device or you may upgrade
your system software or later, let's say,
if you add a tablet or add a new device and
you log on with the same account, if you paid
for that premium title, you will have access
to it, and you only need to pay for it once,
and you also get all subsequent updates to
the application as well, without having to
pay again.
Obviously, for updates, you can also launch,
you know, version 2, Version 3 as a separate
title that you can charge again. But that,
you know, has its ramifications by itself,
which is you're kind of splitting your install
base. But that's a different topic.
So that's free and premium.
And then, finally, there's trial, where you
typically have a light version, sometimes
limited by functionality, or maybe it's time-bound,
whereby the user can upgrade to a full version
if they like what they see in the free version.
This model is particularly popular in premium
games. We see a lot of premium games that
have a light version and a full version. And,
in fact, as an anecdotal kind of example,
when we feature something in the Google Play
Store, let's say we feature a paid title or
premium title, we very often see a big jump
not just in that title, but also in the free
version of that title as well. So users always
look at these things. Paid, sometimes they'll
go to the free and if they like what they
see, they come back to pay for the paid version.
Let's talk about freemium. Freemium is a very
popular topic today, and I'm sure a lot of
you are hearing about it because of the success
that's getting. Freemium is largely possible
because of in-app billing capabilities. The
user downloads the game or app for free, and
further down the line in the application,
you have different in-app products that are
offered to users, such as virtual currency,
special items, or digital content that you
purchase within the app itself. This is a
great model, because it allows your users
to download it without having to pay for it,
invest some time in learning how the game
works or what the app does, and then have
further offerings for them to purchase. Obviously,
some apps are better suited for freemium.
We've seen a lot of successes in social casual
games. Some other applications may not suit
this form of payment very well. Or this type
of payment very well, which is, for example,
like productivity or business. For example,
imagine if you have a spreadsheet, and if
you charge 50 cents every time somebody wants
to print something or format a paragraph,
that's not so cool.
So some category of applications work; some
don't in the freemium case.
So let's take a look at how in-app billing
works. I was giving you kind of a quick run-through
of an example. This is based on the sample
code which is available on developer.android.com.
We'll do a quick run-through.
So, first, Google Play client application
which is on the device plays a very central
role in letting your application work with
the Google Play server.
So your application actually never really
has to talk to the server except through this
Google Play client.
We have something which is called market billing
service within the client. And this is when
you actually set up in purchases, you set
up your product catalogue through the publisher
console. And you can set different currencies
and so forth by publishing them through the
Google Play publisher console. And your application
would reference, right, as you -- as you build
your application, your application will be
making -- exposing those products available
for purchase within the application. And you
can build your application logic around it.
Now, typically, this is how an application
would be set up. And, again, this is structured
after the sample code that we have on developer.android.com.
But, typically, you would have a building
service set up. The billing service makes
requests, sends billing requests to the market
billing service. You have a billing receiver,
which receives asynchronous messages back
from the server. You also have maybe a couple
classes to response -- to respond to the messages
that you receive through the response handler.
And then you may have a purchase op server
so that when you confirm that something has
been transacted, you reflect it in the UI.
And you may also have a security module within
the client itself to handle various different
security aspects.
And then optionally, you can also set up your
own server to store your transaction status.
It's not something that's required, but it's
something that's probably good to have. In
the cases where you delivered content, for
example, it's good to have your own server
and also maybe do tracking of transactions
and also security validations separately from
the application, which is probably from a
best practice perspective better than storing
that security mechanism in the client.
And lastly, there are two types of in-app
purchases, one which is managed; another which
is unmanaged.
So managed is very similar to when you buy
an application, where the Google Play Store
will actually keep track of those services
-- of those items that have been purchased.
Unmerchandising is something which the Google
Play Store will help you with the transaction
flow but let you manage after that in terms
of who has rights to what and so forth.
So let's take a quick look at how a request
is made for a purchase.
Before this actually happens, you actually
make a call to the Google Play -- Again, this
is still on the client. You make a call to
the Google Play client to see what type of
billing is supported and what version.
After you do that, after you check that you
actually does -- that the client actually
does support in-app billing, then you send
a billing request with something called a
request purchase, and you get back a bundle
with response code, a purchase intent, and
a request ID. What the purchase intent is,
remember when we were talking about earlier
that you -- your application provides the
application interface, but the Google Play
Store client actually provides the transaction
interface. Okay? So this is where the purchase
intent comes into play.
Next, you get that intent. You're at the application.
The user now wants to purchase, let's say,
a sort. And now you start the intent. It goes
into the Google Play interface. And here's
a quick code snippet of how this will work.
The first section is setting up that request
purchase. You put in a product ID, and you
also put in a product type. Product type would
be either it's an in-app or a subscription.
We'll talk about subscription in a little
bit.
Once you set up the request bundle, then you
basically send it to M SVS. M service is the
market billing service. You trigger send billing
request, you send over that request, and you
get back a -- a pending intent. The intent
where you launch the Google Play UI.
Okay. And then, finally, your application
can pop that up, the screen, for purchasing.
And when the transaction is completed -- and
"completed," it could mean it actually went
through or the user somehow cancelled -- you
get a broadcast intent. So the broadcast intent
is called in-app notify.
Once you get that, you as an application can
now send another billing request to get the
purchase information, all right? So the server
tells you, Google market -- Google Play tells
you, hey, the transaction is done. Now go
get that purchase information. And you get
another broadcast intent, which is called
purchase state change. And with it, you get
a JSON string, which contains things like
the order ID, the product ID, purchase time.
And we'll talk about purchase token later
on when we're in subscription. But, basically,
you get the information back from Google Play
Store about that transaction.
Now, you also have to -- once you get that
is to confirm those notifications. If you
don't confirm, the Google Play client -- Google
Play server will continue to send you these
notifications, these broadcast intents, the
in-app notify. So once you've processed the
transaction and you say -- let's you made
it available to the user, you want to make
sure that you respond to that notification
so that the server knows that transaction
has been completed.
All right. So that's kind of how -- how the
flow works.
And let's switch gears a little bit. And we're
going to talk about a case study now that
you know roughly how it works.
We're going to talk about a game called Tiny
Village which is by a company called TinyCo.
This is an interesting case study, because
this game was launched back in -- a few months
ago, back in December. It's a free to play
game with in-app purchases. It's gotten 4.5
stars from users. So it's pretty popular,
users are pretty happy about it. It's gotten
more than 3 million downloads. But in that
short period of time, I think what's really
interesting is that Tiny Village is now number
eight overall in top grossing in those few
short months.
In the casual game category, it's number one
in top grossing, and number nine in top three.
And you've also heard earlier that they have
experienced really good RPRU (phonetic) per
paying user as well.
So the game goes like this. Just a quick overview
of what the game does so we can go through
the other examples, is that you're building
a village, and you have different types of
currencies. You can raise dinos, dinosaurs,
you can build your stores, you can build houses,
you can ask your employees or the villagers
to go work. They will pay you taxes. They
will give you currencies. You have special
items that you can collect. You see the -- the
Android there, the Android statue there.
But the point of the game is, you can actually
run through this game play, you know, with
the option to either pay or not pay. If you
look at the top, we have some coins there.
The coins are where you collect from taxes
or, you know, from the dinosaurs. And you
can use them to build new things.
And the crystals on the left, those blue crystals
a lot of times are used to accelerate the
game play. So rather than spending 2,000 coins,
you can spend 50 crystals. And those 50 crystals
are something that you can purchase in packs.
So that's the basic premise of the game.
So why is it successful, we asked.
So some of the strategies that we talked about
and that they focused on were how you engage
users.
So we'll take a look at how TinyCo has managed
to engage users through the 50 levels of this
game. How do you convert users to paying users.
Right? How do you get over the free -- the
free users and get them to actually pay for
in-app items?
And once they start paying, how do you monetize
them more?
And then, finally, how do we manage user retention
so people -- the users are interested to continue
to come back.
So here's this chart regarding, you know,
engagement. A lot of times engagement is measured
by active users. So on the Y axis, this is
where see DAUs, which is daily active users.
And it's very typical to see a game where
the daily active users as the game progresses
-- you know, on the X axis, this is where
the levels of the game, the 50 levels are.
As the level progresses, you have less daily
active users.
Now, what is interesting was that you see
this hump between levels 28 and 34.
What they found out was, you know, as this
trend goes down, if you actually target those
users with specific exclusive features, you
can really effect the engagement of those
users very, very effectively.
As you can see, the interpreted is going down
but they actually did something that with
these exclusive features to bump up the daily
active users. So there are a lot of things
that you can do and we will look into some
of those.
Now, regarding pricing in terms to convert
users, what they also did was look at various
different items that has a low-priced version,
mid-priced version and high-priced version
with differences in those items. If you look
at the folks, the users who bought those versions.
For the low-priced versions, there were more
new users, newly converted users. They are
more attracted to the low priced items versus
existing users. You see a pretty good progression,
where when you go to the high-priced version,
more of the existing users buy it rather than
the newly-converted users.
So as a continuation of that, what they discovered
is higher level users, high level players
really spend on items that have higher returns.
So for example, you may be buying 99 cent
crystals in the beginning, I'm going to try
this out. As you mature to the later level
of the game, you see people buying larger
amounts maybe with a discount, maybe with
larger returns. They also ran a limited mini
game with premium features which resulted
in much higher returns and happier players.
And here's some of the stats. When they ran
this campaign with this mini game, number
of paying customers went up 40%. Average user
spent went over by about 30%. Most importantly,
revenues almost doubled. So here are some
of the things that you can actually do to
affect picking wisely about who your players
are, consumers are and targeting them appropriately.
So about user retention. Some of the things
that are really important is launching content
frequently. In this particular type of game,
it is to be able to attract the users. They
get distracted, they are attracted to come
back and see what's new. So as you can see
here, there are things like, hey, you know,
you have been playing with the game for a
while, how about building a village road trip?
And then after a while, once you start building
their village road trip, how about building
a statue so that you're tourists are going
to come and see this golden statue. Very many
interesting things that you can launch frequently
to kind of track where the user is and attract
them to come back.
Secondly, it's about timely and relevant incentives.
So actually I was playing this game myself
and as I was running out of room on my village,
the next time I launched a game, it told me,
hey, there's an expansion sale, 40% off, because
I was actually running out of room. Now, if
that happened when I just started the game
when I had acres of land or when I had lots
of land, that wouldn't make sense at all.
So timing with the relevant content is very
important. And then finally, expanding beyond
the game itself, having social engagement.
As you can see here introducing Betsy, introducing
to the TinyCo community where you actually
invite and see other people's villages. Not
just building a network, but building that
into a game play. So on the right there is
Hotel Prehistoria, you can look at other people's
villages but put them into your own hotel
as well. That also includes things like notifications,
right, so if it notices that you haven't been
engaged with the game for a while, it would
gently nudge you through notifications to
tell you, hey, here are some incentives to
come back into the game.
The key point is to not just blindly put these
incentives out or launch or content updates,
but it's really to iterate very quickly. Launch
these campaigns, find out if they are successful.
Iterate it, and if something is successful,
can you continue and run it. But if it's not,
then do something else. This is something
that they have done really well which is continuous
iteration and really tracking the metrics.
What's also interesting was that, as we were
conversing about why this game is so popular,
was really about optimizing the user experience.
There are many different types of devices
out there in the Android ecosystem. There
are low-powered devices, high-powered devices,
small screens, large screens. What's really
important and what's really interesting is
that you need to cater to each and all of
those users and not just have one single game.
So TinyCo has built a game engine called the
Griffen engine. The Griffen allows you to
optimize the UI for different screen sizes,
difference devices and different aspect ratios.
If the screen is wider, it works just as well.
Smaller or have high density, it works just
as well. Also, looking at the power of the
device, adapt to different frame rates. So
there are lot of animation that goes on. So
depending on the power of the device, make
sure it is not laggy to any of those. So catering
to specific users. And also provide native
performance as well.
So, again, this is a really good example,
and I would encourage you to go talk to TinyCo.
They will be at the sandbox. Andrew is here
-- I don't know if he is here, but a quick
shout-out to share a lot of this information.
Feel free to jump up and ask him questions.
Next let's talk about the paymium model and
the trial paymium model. Paymium model is
really just a paper title. It's a combination
of premium plus in-app purchase. You have
a title that sells and then have additional
items that you sell afterwards within the
game or within the app. Trial paymium is a
variation of that, free initially, you pay
to get the premium, upgrade to paymium and
then additional items after that. They are
not actually many examples. But here's a very
good one which is Draw Something, I'm sure
a lot of you are familiar with by Zinga. Draw
Something, there are two versions. The free
version has in-app purchase items which is
ad driven. There's also a paid version, $2.99
normally with an in-app item and that version
removes the ads within the application. The
reason why we picked Draw Something is, again,
it's a very, very successful title. It's number
one top paid overall and number seven top
grossing overall in the store. The brain and
puzzle, number one top paid, number five top
free, and also occupies the number one and
number three in top grossing with the paymium
version doing a little bit better on the number
one slot there. So here's an example. Again,
this is probably more rare than the common
case, is that they actually have two separate
APKs, two separate titles, published in this
store and so their title is exposed in two
different lists. Because of the popularity
of the game, they actually are in two lists.
Both the top paid and top free. Having to
APKs allows to you do something interesting
with an opportunity to upgrade your free users
to your paid users. So if you look at some
of these install charts, this was a flash
sale which was run recently, just a couple
of weeks ago, and what happened was on the
left it's a free version, on the right is
a paid version. When he they did a flash sale
on the paid version, they actually let the
free users know there's a flash sale and see
what happened to the paid version. So there
are some advantages to actually having multiple
items of your game both as a paymium medium
and as a freemium model.
Next talk into subscription which we launched
at the end of May. What subscription is an
extension of in-app billing. It's an automatic
recurring monthly or yearly method of payment.
It continues until it's canceled. Everything
is managed within the Google Play store. The
user can go in with a normal interface. Now
you see a subscription tab there and you can
actually see, you can uninstall the application
where you get a notification or you can unsubscribe
and cancel your subscription. So as a tension
to what we saw earlier, to the in-app billing,
it's -- we introduced a term which is a thing
called purchase token which associates subscription
ID with user ID. And the subscription continues
to renew itself until a new purchase state
is changed. And that can be a user pressing
-- you know, going into unsubscribing or canceling.
And these could be delivered and communicated
via in-app notifications and also via a server
API, so you can keep track of those subscriptions
yourself via your own server as well.
Okay, so we talked about a lot of these options.
You are probably wondering, which one should
you choose, there are so many of these. Now,
I'm going to show you a quick slide before
we wrap up here is if we look at the top-grossing
lists in the play store. So I took a snapshot
a few days ago. And you see out of the top
20 grossing, 20 of those top grossing in casual
games, they were all freemium. On the left
side, this is applications, none of them,
if you look at these types of applications,
the ones that are successful by looking at
the top grossing list, you can see that it
depends on which application. All right, this
is how consumers are responding to different
business models. Is that, yes, there are things
like casual games, carts and casino, social,
focusing on the freemium. So it depends on
what your application is. So key take-aways.
Number one, find the model and pricing that
suits you. Take a look at these titles that
are successful, what their price range is
to be competitive and what your offering is.
Number two, find the best ways to engage users
through frequent updates and promotions, timely
incentives, launch relevant targeted content.
Convert those users to paying customers. And
test often. I can't stress enough, test often,
gauge success, iterate, and repeat. Optimize
user experience across devices. Integrate
with social and do cross promotions. And really
most importantly as a part of this talk is
to build monetization strategy into your app
development efforts.
All right, so with that I will pass it back
to Chrix to talk about advertising.
>>Chrix Finne: Cool, Kenneth, thank you. There's
a lot here, right. I don't know if I could
even pair it back all those eight different
things Kenneth just asked me to do. That's
sort of, I think, highlights the need for
any individual app developer to have a deep
understanding of what their users are doing,
what the right model is for them. In advertising
is many different things that we are going
to talk about that. I thought it might be
useful to actually just talk for a little
bit about where the ad dollars come from.
It's not just sort of an magic money box.
Let's go back and talk about how advertising
was born. I like to watch Mad Men. I don't
know if you guys do. It's a show on AMC, and
it's about advertising, right? Advertising
came about when mass media came about really.
The first mass media was the newspaper. And
what happened is that businesses who had things
to sell and wanted to reach customers and
distribute their product realized that there
were people reading newspapers all around
the country and around the world and that
they could actually find new customers by
promoting those businesses, right? So this
is how advertising was born. The old joke
is that newspapers aren't actually selling
news to their readers but they are just selling
the readers to the advertisers, in a sense.
But of course over time as new forms of mass
media have developed, advertising has gone
with that. So in the last 50 years we have
seen television, Internet, and now mobile.
On Mad Men the protagonist is this guy name
Don Draper who is this cool cat who creates
ads. He creates these compelling and engaging
ads which compel people to go buy a Kodak
slide projector or go smoke Lucky Strikes
cigarettes. And I think that if Don Draper
were alive today, he would be building mobile
apps. This is really just the beginning. Advertisers
are only starting to create cool experiences.
You may have seen cool ad experiences on tablets
that I see you all using today and stuff like
that. But mobile really is the future of advertising.
Almost a platitude at this point. People are
thinking how they can be the Don Draper of
today to reach audiences and build compelling
ad experiences and that's what drives value.
I think one thing that I might suggest as
homework, if you are trying to think about
how these agencies think about advertising
and think about connecting with their user
bases is to go to dietcoke.com in one tab
and cokezero.com in another tab and try and
guess who each of those brands is targeting.
So, what about app?S we've talked a lot, like
Kenneth has been talking about how users are
diverse and how all these different business
models can play together. We know people like
apps but really, people really, really like
free apps. 68% of the apps in the Google Play
store are free. Many of those are supported
by advertising. So advertising is an ongoing
revenue stream and it can be done in any scale.
Whether it's a small app just growing and
no matter how big it is, the advertising can
grow with you. There's nothing advertisers
love more than a place where they can reach
millions of customers that all maybe want
the same thing. So how do we bring this together?
This is where you guys come in. At developers,
mobile applications can become that newspaper
publisher that connect businesses to their
potential new customers. We can help do you
that by connecting through advertisers with
AdMob. It's advertising is something that
you can scale with your app. On the other
side, this is just worth mentioning as a side
note, you can actually become an advertiser
yourself using the AdMob network you can promote
your app to users on over 300,000 of the apps
on our network, and you can even also use
Google search to promote your app now, too.
This talks more to the point about distribution
we were talking about earlier, but you can
actually get distribution through advertising
which can be really, really powerful as well.
And one thing that I think is really neat
that we announced a few weeks ago that the
AdMob ad network is now connected to the AdWords
advertising platform. If anybody has ever
bought ads on Google, you would have used
AdWords, AdWords is used by literally million
of advertisers around the world to confine
customers. We do that on Google search. We
do that on ad sense today. On the web, which
you've probably all seen, and now it's actually
possible on AdMob as well. We are starting
to see these advertisers.
While their Don Draper creative directors
helped them move into Mobile and move into
apps, and we're really excited to see a much
wider divert of advertisers going into the
future now that we have this connection to
AdWords because, you know, a lot of the advertising
up until this point on Mobile has been, you
know, for other apps or sort of Mobile focus
things and we're trying to grow that pie into
any type of advertiser which is really exciting.
So how can you build a business with your
app? Once you've installed the Google AdMob
STK, it's pretty simple, you can choose where
you want to put your ads, and then we display
ads in the app, and then if users click on
the ads and like them, our advertisers pay
us and we give the lion's share back to you
guys and you get paid every time a user clicks
on the app. This is pretty basic.
So how does that actually work, though? This
is just some terminology to quickly go through
here. When you serve an ad in your app, we
call that an impression. Say you have a bunch
of users and you serve 100,000 impressions,
that means that hopefully some of those users
will find value from those ads and click on
them so that creates a click-through rate,
let's say 1 1/2% of those impressions get
clicked on, that means that you actually end
up with 1500 clicks, right, and then we charge
advertisers when a user clicks on their ad,
and so we then figure out what the price should
be through an auction, we sort of set a market
price on that click, and then let's say your
cost-per-click is 10 cents or something. What
that means is you just made $1,500 from those
100,000 impressions. And then the other word
in the business that we use is RPM which is,
sorry, simply revenue per thousand impressions,
so RPM in this example would be $1.50.
So how do you implement these ads? It's actually
pretty simple. This is the on-create method
of a fake Android app we have in our sample
library on code.google, and basically all
we're doing here is making sure we're in our
main content view, we're creating a new ad
view object, which has in it the ad unit ID
you can get once you sign up on AdMob and
then we basically add the ad view to our layout
and then create an ad request at the end of
this method here.
So as you can see, we have an ad type banner
which is a sort of basic type and the ad12345
is your site ID that you signed up for online.
One thing that we announced back in April
that we think is pretty cool is this thing
called smart banners. One thing that you guys
may have noticed is that there's lots of different
Android devices out there today and they have
different screen sizes, right? It can be tricky
that your app actually renders for all these
different screen sizes and then ads on top
of that, it gets kind of annoying, I think,
at times. Three devices you are all getting
for free? I think they all have three different
screen sizes. Anyway, smart banners is actually
a simple but kind of clever optimization that
we do on your behalf, if you implement smart
banners, you don't actually have to worry
about the width of the screen that you're
going to show the ad on. We will actually
grow the ad and shrink the ad in horizontal
dimension to make sure it fits. So you don't
end up with those sort of ugly bars and they
can fit big or small, portrait to landscape,
it's pretty neat.
So let's talk about what you actually -- what
we should think about when implementing your
ads. This all gets back to figuring out your
user engagement patterns and figuring out
what the right place is to actually do this
sort of thing is. It's going to be different
for every app. So number one, we think it's
important to really build your app with ads
in mind, right? It's not really good if you
don't set expectations off the bat that there
are going to be ads in your app and if you
add them in later your users might not be
very happy about that, right? Two is if you
have search that's pretty cool, we'll talk
about this in a minute but we have a special
way of showing ads if your users are searching
for something or issuing some sort of query
so we can target the ads much better so that's
pretty cool. And then yeah, you have to pay
attention to your user engagement, if you
know what your users are doing you shouldn't
screw them up through an ad because that's
not good for anyone. Interrupting in the middle
of a game might not make sense. Maybe it makes
sense at the end of the level when the user
will do something else and won't be as interrupted
by the ad. That gets to number four is that
really try and avoid accidental clicks. You
know, it's sometimes easy, there's not a lot
of real estate on these phones. Don't put
ads in your controls and things, right, the
screen is small and if that generates accidental
clicks, it's a bad user experience, people
are going to be, oh, I don't like that, I
didn't mean to click on this ad. And, you
know, you need to make sure user engagement
comes first, right? And that's accidental
clicks also reduce value for advertisers.
And over time that means you won't make as
much money, right, the advertisers are going
to react and our system will react, so to,
you know, price those lower value clicks lower
so let's talk about a few examples. First
is a Korean app called SimSimi, this is an
AI robot from a developer in Korea. So you
can send a message to SimSimi and it will
send you a message back. So this was really
popular in Korea when they first launched.
But SimSimi thought they would try to expand
out globally. They realized it would be difficult
to acquire paid users in lots of different
countries because there was some craziness
with billing and such like that so they tried
to do a free approach in some of these markets
using advertising. So these ad revenues allowed
them to scale up quickly around the world,
download soared to about 15 million and now
80% of their downloads are actually from these
markets outside of Asia. Now, this is a great
example of how you can build a real global
business using a combination of advertising
and other methods and we have a nice quote
from their CEO about how they expanded globally
and their advertising revenues actually ended
up exceeding their paid revenues in this case.
Something I alluded to a minute ago about
search ads. This is something I think Google
does uniquely well. If you have an app that
actually users are interact in a search kind
of way we can show you highly targeted search
ads that are of more user and of a higher
value that are the more generic display ads
that are sort of the norm. And so Around Me
is an app that lets users search for things
around them, restaurants, bars, sort of a
local search, and they implemented a search
ad which you can see at the top there, it's
a, yeah, a local bank ad, I guess, and by
doing this they were able to actually earn
three times higher RPMs than they were regular
display ads and five times higher click-through
rates using these search ads. They're called
custom search ads for mobile apps and that's
something you can learn more about at the
developers' sandbox tomorrow.
Let's talk for a few minutes, we only have
a few minutes left about other ad networks.
We know AdMob isn't the only ad network in
the market. Maybe you tried one ad network
to start out with but things are fluctuating,
it's a dynamic market, and no ad network is
created equal. These RPMs fluctuate and ECPMs
fluctuate depending on all sorts of factors,
seasonality, demand, and some ad networks
have different strengths, for instance, some
are very strong in emerging markets, where
others may not be, so it varies per country,
too. And so soon enough you have three or
four different ad network STKs on your app
and they're all fluctuating. So what do you
do? You end up mediating. By installing a
mediation layer, you can actually hopefully
end up ride that curve and figure out what
your optimal ECPM is from combining all those
networks.
Mediation acts like a railroad switch. There's
a sort of a wrapper SDK which then controls
which SDKs it requests ads from. We launched
an AdMob mediation product in April which
is a free and open feature, part of the AdMob
product, which lets you use almost any ad
network, and it's also built on Google infrastructure
and lets you choose basically how to organize
those ad networks, whether it's by sort of
percentage basis of traffic or which of them
hides the sort of highest ECPMs at the moment.
It also has sort of a nice dashboard, this
is just a picture of the dashboard, which
as you can see there, you're picking which
ad network you want to enable, which order
they're in and what their sort of expected
payouts will be. And one of the great things
about our AdMob mediation product is that
it's super simple to integrate. This is the
same code we looked at a minute ago about
how to set up an ad view. To set up a mediation
ad view, all you need to do is so and sign
up for mediation on our Web site and you get
a new mediation ID which you simply replace
your reg ad unit ID with your mediation ID
and you're done. So this is really neat. You
can then simply compile the additional ad
network STKs and we do all the plumbing for
you. It's actually pretty sweet.
So that's a nice -- mediation is a nice way
to optimize your ads once you figure out where
they should go and how they should best interact
with your users.
So, yeah, just there are a lot to anybody
here, right? We want to help you guys make
money, we want to partner with you because,
you know, it's something that we like to do
at Google is partner with app developers,
obviously. And there's a lot of different
products here. You know, we think that we
have a pretty flexible and comprehensive advertising
platform as well as a direct monetization
platform with Google Play and hopefully those
are, between the two, how you can make the
most money from your app on Android and really
build a business out of that. But as we said
in the beginning, the most important thing
here is to understand how to engage with your
users and where and when these types of monetization
options are important. Because if you don't
think critically about that, that's really
the only way to ensure sort of long-term value
from your users and then consequently from
your business.
So I highly encourage you guys to stick around
for the promotion talk now and go to the analytics
talk on Friday as well because I think there's
a lot more to learn about how to actually
learn to manage these parts of your business.
So thank you very much. Thanks again to Kenneth
and I think we're actually about out of time.
So enjoy the rest of the day.
[ Applause ]